lorsqu'on est une star on était pieds de
toutes parts par les magazines people et
les passants dans la rue qui avec leur
téléphone n'hésite pas à saisir chaque
instant de votre intimité
le revers de la médaille que certaines
personnalités alimente un peu plus en
dévoilant ponctuellement au grand public
les détails de leur vie sentimentale
on se souvient par exemple de benjamin
castaldi qui à l'époque animateur sur m6
avait partagé publiquement sa relation
très people avec l'animatrice flavie
flament couverture de magazine interview
rien n'était trop beau pour crier son
amour à qui voulait l'entendre mais
voilà quand les choses tournent mal et
que le couple se sépare cette grande
médiatisation peut se transformer en
véritable cauchemar
on se souvient également de la
mésaventure arrivée à stéphane bern qui
avait fait le choix de poser avec son
compagnon de l'époque lionel en une de
gala une médiatisation qu'il n'avait pas
supporté et qui l'avait poussé à quitter
l'animateur de france 2 cette couverture
a eu un effet que je n'avais pas
escompter ruiné ma vie privée
c'est violent pour l'autre d'être ainsi
exposés alors selon vous faut-il
afficher son couple dans les médias
alors est-ce qu'il faut afficher son
couple dans les médias benjamin castaldi
vous dites oui moi je les fais ouais
j'ai fait je les fais avec la vie après
il ya on improvise et qu'on était
vraiment harcelée par les paparazzi mais
effectivement moi je trouve qu'il vaut
mieux donner comme ça après ils veulent
il veut le cliché l'ont-ils fois
problème mais c'est vrai que voilà vous
avez été beaucoup traquer vous avec
flavia oui mais moi j'ai en fait avec
les j'ai vécu en fait ils ont écrit
l'histoire ils ont une mariage ils
avaient faim la vie enceinte après il ya
eu le divorce la tromperie donc on en a
eu vraiment beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
et c'est très bel et bien il a dit voir
sa tromperie wyeth obama j'ai eu en fait
c'est ça le plus dur c'est quand vous
êtes en séparation il vous avez d une de
voici ou autres où vous découvrez donc
votre ex femme n'est pas encore divorcée
qui était avec un autre ça c'est un
petit peu ça c'est ça c'est un peu ça
fait du mal ce cas là elle fait la une
de voici avec son nouveau compagnon et
ça on le vit très mal voilà non vraiment
ça fait mal à l'époque oui bien sûr même
si vous étiez c'est pareil tout quand
même à lui parce que au début voilà on
est on est comme fragiles en fait le
fait qu'elle soit plus là en même temps
c'était j'ai c'était un peu de ma faute
mais voilà on visualise quoi mais voilà
sur vivalis et afellay mme penchard
compris à chaque fois rien compris radi
après benjamin ya pas que les
paparazzades ya aussi le fait de jeu
alors on invite la presse à son mariage
à l'alluré d'un enfant et tout ça moi je
pense que vivre heureux c'est vivre
caché et je pense que moi on en donne
mieux c'est en fait alors
le nagi c'est pas le seul à parler de sa
femme dans les interviews parce que là
on parle des paparazzi de cela on ne
parle pas que de ça moi je parle aussi
des réseaux sociaux aurait beaucoup de
filles coupe qui s'affiche dans l'est
dans les médias mais aussi sur les
réseaux sociaux qui parlent de leur vie
privée dans la presse on vous a fait une
petite compil et vidéo des couples stars
sur les réseaux à regarder
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
matthieu delormeau le principe d'une
star justement c'est qu'elle est
mystérieuse je ne veux rien savoir et
justement c'est drôle parce que pendant
la pub je demandais justement géraldine
tu lisais mais richard reid est j'étais
marié part marié est ce qu'ils aient des
enfants j'en sais rien et c'est aussi ce
qui fait que les cultures que je très
impressionné d'être en face de lui
aujourd'hui non seulement de l'acteur
elio di rupo
c'est vrai non non je déconne hors du
coup il y aura plutôt parce
qu'effectivement je ne sais rien sur
vous et du coup il ya tout ce mystère
autour du fait que vous êtes une star je
sais pas où il vit je sais pas ce qui
fait comme à jane lis tous ces gens là
ont si rien moi les gens qui étale tout
rien à [ __ ] de savoir qui est une
bagnole qui fait ça ou ils valent
dimanche une star adorée sunstar vous
êtes déjà fiché dans la presse vous vous
étiez drôle d'histoire mais aussi avec
un animateur très connu oui je vous ai
vu faire de nombreuses une daube young
david n'était pas paralysée et si tu
veux tout savoir mon chéri abbas et le
jeu rapide de tout savoir tu veux tous
avancé n'a pas raté donc à l'insu de
notre plein gré donc on a deux choix du
pognon parce qu'on attaque et combien d
un on me l'avait dit une fois seize mois
une fois 16me une fois 5 une fois 5e
d'accord donc à 21,26 j'ai fait un bel
intérieur je manque pas de symétrie subi
mais une fois grands magazines nous
avait proposé deux posé en une contre
d'énormes sommes d'argent est
effectivement de regards s'étaient posés
à la vitesse de café le matin et où on a
dit non direct d'accord et c'était de
grosses sommes d'argent du 100 des 16000
euros par personne quand même ah oui
isabelle bout alors c'est moi qui m'ont
longtemps bossé dans la presse écrite
c'est tout comme de choisir
il ya ceux qui choisissent de ne pas se
montrer comme goldman comme vous ayez
choisi ceux qui choisissent de
médiatiser leur couple est marrant dans
ce qui médiatise leur couple ne peuvent
pas revenir en arrière ensuite on peut
va pendant des années dire je veux qu'on
montre mon cou et brusquement quand ça
devient contre aînés on dire je ne vais
plus qu'à la match les gens vous vous
posez la question c'est faut-il
l'affiché son couple en médaillons
n'aurait pas gênant qu'il le fasse
oui c'est pas génial faut-il le faire
c'est pas moi je réponds clairement oui
merci à partir du moment où c'est une
interview où tout le monde est d'accord
je trouve que c'est lent sur les réseaux
tout ça aussi mais ne viennent pas alors
là ne me gêne pas moi c'est là qu'est né
ce qui me gêne c'est quand c'est
mercantile à des fins financières
d'accord vendre des produits ou quand on
vend une interview sinon afficher son
intimité ou en tout cas son amour dans
les journaux ça ne me gêne pas du tout
mais le coup devenu un code promo ou un
placement de produit
c'est un business aujourd'hui dans la
télé-réalité c'est devenu un business
tout quoi les beckham c'est un business
regarder on a la gnaque sallanches aussi
dans les médias et sur les réseaux
sociaux avec thomas ils ont fait de très
nombreux placements de produits ensemble
et naguila nabila affiche également son
fils millan sur les réseaux sociaux
elle s'est justifiée dans cliquer sur
canal ce nouveau scandale du joueur
tendance à aimer votre enfant est déjà
sur instagram
oui on a posé la question d'exposer ou
pas oui c'est très longue séquence a été
pendant neuf mois pendant neuf mois donc
quand j'étais enceinte
est-ce qu'on veut montrer ce qu'on le
montre pas comment va-t-on faire pour le
cacher quand on va aller en france voir
la famille si quelqu'un prend une photo
et l'avant comment je vais le vivre et
j'avais trop peur de le cacher qu'on me
poursuive pour avoir son visage et je
m'en serais jamais remise si je l'aurais
pas fait - et quelqu'un l'aurait fait à
ma place
j'aurais pété un câble donc je me suis
dit ok voilà alors les coupes qui leur
style s'afficher dans les médias c'est
vrai que tout le monde en a parlé de ça
deux bébés de nabila sur les réseaux
sociaux vous dites quoi tu peux
comprendre son raisonnement à nabila
c'est vrai qu'elle est très exposé c'est
une star de télé réalité elle fait son
beurre avec instagram etc les réseaux
sociaux donc elle sera traqué de toutes
façons est tout le monde ouvre à une
photo de l'enfant
donc elle a sans doute raison de le
gérer comme ça après quand ça devient un
enfant marketé quand ça devient un
produit financier consomment bien un
échange marketing moi ça me dérange
quand même profondément voilà est-ce que
les coupes doit s'afficher dans
l'immédiat les couples oui moi je crois
que non d'accord avec géraldine je pense
qu'il faut rester caché pense qu'il faut
pas trop chercher après ça dépend aussi
si on avait quelqu'un d' exposer ou pas
je suis avec quelqu'un qui fait un
métier qui n'a pas forcément envie lui
d'être exposés bah ouais je suis seul
avec mon club house et quoique je
travaillais le temps pour amener à vous
le temps que le magazine sorte je suis
déjà plus avec donc cette année ça me
gênerait pas ça me gênerait pas de
m'afficher bâtiment une ruade afficher
son bonheur
je n'aime pas mais vous dites oui quel
est l'événement depuis tout à l'heure je
sais pas pourquoi paris mais vous avez
dit ferme ta gueule d'un pas du tout
maintenant regarder un truc non mais je
trouve ces moyennes certaine hypocrisie
je ne crois pas une seule seconde nabila
qui se dit je me suis posé des questions
très bon non pas par homophobie comme à
deux secondes
elle savait très bien qu'elle pose texte
allait faire le buzz à les nourrir tout
son business extra je ne critique pas
c'est la société qui veut ça mais moi je
suis pas du tout dans la peau de la
placement de produit j'en fais pas mais
en revanche
je pose pas grand chose parce que j'ai
pas grand chose à poster mais si j'avais
et si j'étais heureux avec une femme ça
veut dire ne pas le montrer et donc
voudrait qu'ils abritent pariseau
mathieu secret dit pas ça les stars de
terre et est aujourd'hui la grande
marcel des marseillais les ch'tis tout
ça gagnent entre cinquante et cent
cinquante mille euros par mois avec leur
énorme
jusque là pas de problème le problème
c'est que tout est si j'avais aussi à w9
un petit peu tout maintenant des enfants
et vous regarder leurs enfants parfois
même avant de naître ont déjà un compte
instagram et il ya des bébés vous voyez
bébé quand vous cliquez sur bébé il ya
toutes les marques mix à ta ta ta ta ta
temps le baiser le bébé a lui même va
apporter 30 à 40000 euros par mois ce
qui me choque c'est qu'on ne donne pas
au choix déjà ne donne pas le choix ce
bébé de devenir connus ou pas et comme
disait un psy on ne sort jamais indemne
de la célébrité
ces mômes n'ont déjà pas le choix est on
en train de faire une génération mais de
futurs jordi et ça va être un drive
ainsi nantes à 10 ans 18 très mal et
magnéto sont bien fait parce que vous
avez pris le self en berne
vous avez au champion qui émanait d'asie
au monde
il a fait du bon boulot si vous avez
pris une baffe les fans berne et
benjamin flavie elle était connue et le
copain de ses fans n'étaient pas connues
et c'est ça les dégâts c'est citer deux
qui sont connus c'est pas très grave que
tu ailles dans la presse et que tu
révèles mais si l'autre à n'est pas
connu moi pas par exemple moi aller dans
la rue comme je suis pas commis les gens
d'y hâter le maître d'hanouna c'est à
dire que c'est moi du temps distincts le
mec de chez nous la jeunesse rappelle
armand il m'appelle gaston il m'appelle
il sert pas certains encore à resituer
hélas la personne qui sera avec moi ils
vont dire c'est là la meuf de un thème
hanouna reçoit jamais elle la personne
concernée et la va vite
voilà elle a peut-être sans vie dont
quand les deux sont connus
moi je pense qu'il faut exposer parce
que ces deux personnes publiques quand
les deux sont pas connues c'est à
l'autre de demander est ce que tu veux
être dans les magazines et il avait
donné son accord à la compagnie
et il se dit liliane les deux belle
kelly moi je pense que les célébrités
reçoivent tellement d'amour de leur
femme que tu qu'ils ont aussi un peu
envie de leur donner de leur vie privée
pour justement partagé avec eux donc moi
ça me ça me choque pas les gens qui
s'affiche non-jeu pourquoi pas vu deux
chars toi c'est vrai qu'on s'est jamais
rires tu t'es jamais exposé itajai me
l'a jamais eue non vous j'ai toujours
protégé ce à quoi je me lâche je suis
assez d'accord soit toujours protégé
c'est mon point de vue maintenant on
sait que de l'attitude saint leu ce que
pense géraldine chantiers encore
l'attitude de jean jacques goldman c'est
parfait et voilà on aime quelqu'un pour
ce qu'il fait pour son oeuvre pour son
travail après sa vie privée c'est lui
c'est n'appartient et j'ai pas envie
j'ai pas envie de savoir ce qui se passe
dans sa vie m'intéresse pas je veux
juste continuer à composer des belles
choses où vous jouer ou chanter des
belles choses mais c'est tout la vie
privée ça ne m'intéresse pas mais vous
habitez vers vu par exemple vous
n'habite pas loin et ne dit pas non plus
envie de voir ta gueule mais juste faut
aussi voir que quand on donne une photo
après ça dévalorise la paparazzade c'est
une façon avoir la paix aussi une séance
photo comme ça on a parlé de ces faits
on sait avec quelle lui je pars à penser
qu on a beau s'y essayer d'être discret
ne pas vouloir s'exposer à après je ne
sais pas comment ça se passe enfin j'ai
vécu un petit peu il ya longtemps il ya
la traque
ça s'est compliqué à gérer et surtout
dans une maternité quand les grands des
stars accouchait les paparazzi partout
qui essayent de s'infiltrer qui sont
passés par fois pour les infirmiers etc
parce que même compliqué quand on
devient maman pour la première fois ou
pharma on va voir ce qu'en pense la
télémaintenance nom de s'auto de
regarder faut-il of wwii à 24 ans son
nom à benoît 16 % vous avez voté c'est
donc le nom qui remporte un large
suffrages